the solitary confinement you're in a
cell 20 to 23 hours a day I recently
discovered in a number of states on the
weekend you're actually in the cell
round-the-clock for the whole weekend
you don't come out for meal so you have
a slot in the door where your meals are
given to you there's often very little
that's in your cell some states only
allow you one book some allow a book
shelf worth of things some states no TV
no radio other states all right
many states restrict the number of
visitors the lack of any kind of human
contact even when you have those visits
you're typically allowed out for one
hour a day of exercise which some people
say is kind of in a dog exercise yard
because it's a kind of pen that's
attached to the prison if you want to do
your exercise for an hour that means you
probably don't have time for a telephone
call or two or to take a shower and you
are literally kept in isolation for a
long isolation from any human contact
psychologists and other doctors who've
studied this say that people decompose
they lose their mind they begin for
example if they've been so isolated for
so long then they're in human contact
suddenly there can be the stimulation of
just a fly in the room and they'll be
staring and looking at that fly and
can't concentrate because they're over
stimulated by that in some solitary
confinement the lights are kept on all
the time people can be a number in the
south that don't have any
air-conditioning so we've had a number
of deaths in people in solitary and non
solitary because of the excess of heat
it's a unimaginable way of keeping
people and it's extraordinary and when I
tell people this people think I'm making
it up and the fact that we have tens of
thousands of people at any one moment
who
are in this existence and we've had some
people who have spent literally decades
in this existence in the United States
so often when we talk about prisons and
jails we talk about the numbers how many
people in prison or how many people in
jail what we overlook is that we have
some of the most degrading dehumanizing
prisons and jails in any developed
country the data that I have put
together I would say from based on
recent reports we have about eighty nine
thousand to one hundred and twenty
thousand people at any one time in
solitary confinement recent report that
came out from the Bureau of Justice
Statistics says within the last year
about eighteen to twenty percent of the
people in jail or prison have
experienced solitary confinement at some
point so a much higher portion of people
is actually going through that even
though at any one time it may be like
between 3% and 14% of the state prison
population but many more people are
being affected by it to put some context
into that the UN rapat or several years
ago said anything more than 15 days in
isolation is considered torture and the
UN is expected any day now to approve
the new standard rules for the minimum
treatment of prisoners which haven't
been revised in almost half a century
and they're going to be renamed the
Mandela rules and one of the rules that
the UN General Assembly is expected to
approve is that prolonged solitary
confinement is not acceptable is not a
standard and that it should not be over
15 days and it shouldn't be used for
juveniles and it shouldn't be used for
the mentally ill at all not even a few
days
you